Chris Pratt and Anna Faris are  separating the couple shared the news on  social media Sunday night in a joint  statement they explained quote we are  sad to announce we are legally  separating we tried hard for a long time  and were really disappointed we still  love each other and will always cherish  our time together Chris and Anna met in  2007 on the set of take me home tonight  this is a big step okay but I think it's  the right thing no yes they got married  in 2009 and welcomed their son Jack in  2012 we have a beautiful little son and  then we try hard to really appreciate  that the quieter times and and then  spend quality time with each other et  spoke with Chris in April at his  Hollywood Walk of Fame ceremony right  after Anna gave a touching speech I'm  speechless I was moved to tears several  times I'm here with my whole family it's  a really special moment